Vizio is now with this story
about to be a fan of the Tim Dylan show
I can always point to I saw when David
dobrik had that issue he I said he's
about to become a fan of the Tim Dillon
show you can always pinpoint the moment
in someone's career when they become a
fan of the Tim Dillon show lizzo whether
you know it or not you are about to
become a fan of the Tim Dylan show
because now you're going to start to
hear things with uh virginiers new new
you're going to be it's virgin ears
because the you're going to actually
hear me for the first time
after this event you're going to hear me
for the first time and you're going to
go you know
some of what he's saying makes sense
um number one what a mistake
to hire 10 lizos to to be if you look or
sound like me I'm throwing you in front
of a train
there is zero
this idea that she's gonna create a
community of fat lizos that are all
going to get along and love each other
that they're not going to turn around
and go why is this [__] the lead when
they all look like her
and they all are icing their [__]
ankle after the number and everybody is
going why is this [__] that so what
lizzo tried to do is she said we're
gonna have a show called watch out for
the big girls where I'm gonna get all
these fat backup dancers and I'm gonna
put them behind me and it's gonna be a
celebration of the body and of the big
girls dancing and everything like that
and and then so predictably like
everything they turned on her they
turned on lizzo number one they turn on
her because they said they were weight
shamed by lizzo
because there's a point when you're too
fat
and lizzo probably said listen we're all
fat we gotta behave here because when
you have so many fat people
together
they can influence each other in
negative ways
and maybe lizzo walks in on two of these
dancers and they are eating a peanut
butter out of the jar together and and
pawing it out like the Poo would with
honey you know two of them are in the
room and Liza goes well oh hey guys we
got rehearsal right now and these women
are they just have their fingers in the
jar of peanut butter and they're just
licking it off and lizard goes listen
I'm a fat [__] I get it but you have to
be professionally fat
you know so this is the issue when you
have a bunch of fat people and bat is
all you everybody you know it's like a
bunch of chunkies I've been in a house
with a bunch of junkies and then certain
people start deciding who's at like
being too much of a junkie
I used to hang out in crack houses where
certain people would like they'd be
sober for an hour and they would turn
around to somebody else and they'd go
you got to get your act together because
that's what junkies do in the same way
when you have a bunch of fat people and
somebody's been on keto for 13 minutes
they start looking at everybody else
going look at this fat pig look at that
piece of [__] huh there is a dysfunction
inherent in such a community where all
of these people are big
it's a thing you're not everybody's not
supposed to be fat
everybody's not supposed to be gay
everybody's not supposed to be anything
they're supposed to be you know you it's
like a little bit you give a couple of
fat people here a couple of gay people
here a couple of trans people here it
makes it interesting not ever not
everybody Oberlin College 70 of you
can't be gay non-binary LGBT whatever
that's not the thing
like it's a sprinkling you can't just
have every fat person in the world on a
tour bus can you imagine
lizzo's tour bus
pulling up in your town
and it's just one after the other it's
almost like these the eight Wonders of
the Seven Wonders of the World
when every single woman gets off that
tour bus each one fatter than the last
and they go that's the concert those are
the dancers
formalizo dancers were weight shamed and
pressured while at a strip club here's
the other thing I want to say if you're
a fat person and you hire fat people one
of the fun things to do is to call them
fat
you can't call your thin employees fat
although that is fun too and uh you know
if you are thin it's mean to call fat
people fat but but it's kind of like the
n-word which I don't use because I'm not
black
but if I have a fat employee I should be
able to call them fat fatty boom Baddie
I should be able to call them piglet I
should be able to make jokes about their
weight because I am also fat and that
entitles me to make jokes about their
weight and demean them and if they can't
handle that they should not have taken
the job that is one of the benefits of a
fat person who hires fat people uh and
you you Curry favor with your thin
employees by brutalizing the fat ones in
front of the thin ones I will make fun
of my fat employee in in front of one of
my thin ones and the fat one you know
frumply goes away sad into the other
room and me and the thin one have that
moment of like look what we just did to
that fatty it's a bonding experience
okay
like we're not We're Not Gonna surf
together me in the thin one but we can
make fun of the the pig I've hired now
so lizzo
and by the way lizzo is smoking a joint
right now in West Hollywood listening to
this going God I wish this didn't make
sense I wish this didn't make sense
three of lizzo's former dancers have
accused the singer of sexual harassment
and creating a hostile work environment
in a lawsuit filed Tuesday they also
allege that she pressured one of them to
touch a nude performer at an Amsterdam
Club they went to a strip club and
subject of the group to quote
excruciating audition uh an excruciating
audition after leveling false
accusations that they were drinking on
the job so they're basically saying
she's some type of emotional terrorist
going after everybody accusing them of
drinking haranguing them about their
weight and when they go to a strip club
I think I read the thing about the strip
club she was basically like touch this
naked uh male dancer and she'd like got
a chant going like do it do it do it the
person felt uncomfortable and then they
finally did it and uh you know it's kind
of like drunken Shenanigans at a strip
club I mean I know that you know certain
people will see that as inappropriate to
me
I don't know
um
you know I don't know how the
inappropriate that is it's not like Liz
was going around
uh sexually harassing the dancers
um you know the suit filed in the Los
Angeles Superior Court and provided to
NBC News by the plaintiff's Law Firm
also accuses the captain of lizzo's
dance team of proselytizing to other
performers and deriding those who had
pre-marital sex while while sharing lewd
fantasy simulating oral sex and publicly
discussing the virginity of one of the
plaintiffs let me read that again
because there's a lot there
um it also accuses the captain of
lizzo's dance team of proselytizing to
other performers so I think she was a
Christian
and she was telling people today she was
kind of being evangelizing and deriding
those who had pre-marital sex so she
said you're a [__] I'm a Christian but
then she was also at the same time
sharing lewd fantasies simulating oral
sex and publicly discussing the
virginity of one of the plaintiffs
um
so we got we got a whole host of uh
issues that
uh these dancers are upset about right
the hostile work environment uh saying
sexual harassment the suit brings claims
for religious and racial harassment
false imprisonment I mean what is that
interference with prospective economic
advantage and other allegations not
every claim is brought against each
defendant I mean listen people can bring
a lawsuit for anything and I'm sure
these lawyers think that they're going
to get a chunk of money or that lizzo is
going to settle this is meant I think to
tarnish Her Image and this will teach
someone a lesson and I think it should
teach lizzo a lesson
um when you elect to be the mayor
of the the fat people and the mayor of
the body positive and the mayor of you
got to remember this folks and I I don't
by the way I don't attack people
um
unless I feel
that a it's funny or B that they are
wrong if they're wrong I will say when
Meghan Markle and Prince Harry do
something I pounce because uh all of the
things that they do are so transparently
vulgar uh most of them are lies and the
ones that aren't lies are distorted uh
to a point where it becomes ridiculous
and all of those things come from a bad
place it's a place of wanting to be
famous wanting to have power over people
wanting to control people wanting to uh
you know force people to believe a
certain thing so that's why I pouncing
them here's the thing with and this is
why I'm not attacking lizzo I don't know
and we've made fun of lizzo a bunch
lizzo forced dancers to eat bananas
from sex workers vaginas during
Amsterdam well this is
[Laughter]
hold on I was just about to say I wasn't
really coming down here hard on lizzo
only because
what I'm saying is when you say hostile
work environment and all these things
right uh I need to know the specifics of
what's going on however this article
seems maybe to provide them lizzo forced
answers
three of lizzo's former dancers are
suing the good as hell performer as well
as big girl
big girl big touring big girl big
touring
and Charlene Quigley for allegedly
subjecting them to endure weight share
okay we know that
okay so apparently the Amsterdam thing
so apparently they were in Amsterdam and
earlier this year and then that's when
the banana incident happened but what is
the banana incident let's let's try to
find this here
uh because again I I have to judge these
claims based on their merits now the
headline is lizzo forced uh
okay here we go
the lawsuit States things quickly got
out of hand at this Amsterdam strip club
lizzo began inviting cast members to
take turns touching the new performers
catching dildos launched from the
performers vaginas and eating bananas
protruding from the performer's vaginas
the suit also claims lizzo allegedly
pressured and goaded someone named Davis
I guess it's one of the dancers yeah I
read this into touching one nude
performer's breasts the plaintiff also
claims that just wants later lizzo 35
deceived them once again into attending
a nude show thereby quote robbing them
of the choice not to participate so what
you have there is lizzo likes to get
maybe some freaky stuff she likes to go
to the strip club she likes to get turnt
up she likes to get wild
she's got bananas it's always food isn't
it she has bananas uh flying out of the
[__] of these dancers and she's
making people eat it it is way over the
line for sure
um but you know did these girls in the
moment have a problem with this or was
this something that after the night out
because I could see this being
uncomfortable but they're all drunk and
lizzo's be like yeah
and then you know the rest of them are
you know everybody's drunk and
everybody's kind of had people kind of
like ooh gross but like nobody really
makes it clear how uncomfortable they
are
um and then they do this stuff and then
they do they decide afterwards like this
is this was way too far this was over
the line I don't know I think I think
lizzo's made a few big mistakes in her
career I think one of them is going
in the direction of virtue
uh and just saying like not just being
like hey I'm fat it is what it is
saying like I'm going I will be your
queen always a mistake
always a mistake
I will be your queen
and then inviting her fat subjects to
the strip club
and then they turn on her because that
never works when you go I'm going to be
your queen it never works lizzo it
doesn't work you you you now have to
understand that you're just a singer
who's fat
you're not it's not a revolutionary
thing
you know how many fat people have talked
to the microphones a lot of them you
know how many fat people have been
famous many many many
even fat black women have been [__]
famous heard of Oprah
you're not the first in line to the
throne here you're the first social
media star
um who's actually a very good singer and
a really great musician
who felt all of this pressure coming at
you from these people to say well our
movement needs a queen be this queen
and you took on that mantle
and now you know people uh in your orbit
have turned on you and they want to take
you off that
throne and they want
you to come in I don't know what lizzo
has lizzo issued a statement had she
denied this I mean has the woman because
all we've heard is from her
uh you know big girls
this is by the way uh completely
predictable in every way
when you watch
the show the big girl show and you see
all these people they all have trauma
right everybody has traumas everybody
goes
you know here's why I'm uh overweight or
here's why I'm big I I have trauma I was
never there so it was never that I was
never respected you know so a lot of
these traumas are going to come out is
her IG being lit up are people like
going crazy on her IG did she lock the
comments yeah she hasn't posted in a
while no but I mean what her most recent
thing usually when scandals happen like
the most recent thing
you know will be like it's very funny
sometimes I mean you'll see like the
most recent photo of somebody they're
like shirtless on a beach and they have
like a goofy caption and then like
literally the next line will be answer
the allegations and it's just like such
a it's like such an unfortunate final
photo to have before social media Hiatus
answer the allegation she was 16.
I don't know what lizzo does now
I don't know if she could does she fight
it
here's what she should do lizzo should
get super thin
it's now time to throw fat people under
the bus
put the ozempic in vain
get hot get thin declare war on fat
people write a book lizzo listen to me
yeah here they are here's a comments so
you're out there fat shaming your
dancers the audacity
read the [__] room you got exposed so
they're coming at lizzo listen to me
listen to the Timberland show I'm gonna
tell you how to be okay
I'm going to tell you listen to me I
want you to look at me I know you're
watching I know people that know you
listen to me
the time for fat is over now you've made
enough money off the pigs
it's time to leave the barn God I could
I could do these I could never stop with
these I could do these for hours it's
time to leave the barn okay
here's what you have to do
you have to get hot you have to write a
book about Wellness you have to go you
have to denounce the fats
you have to say it was all wrong you
were wrong you weren't thinking you were
in a haze of Insomnia Cookies Postmates
you have to
you know you have to it's you you need
to be on The Joe Rogan Experience my
good friend Joe Rogan you go on there
and you say Joe I am thin now a thin
lizzo on The Joe Rogan Experience is the
future of her career
you need to change turn from this fat
mainstream and become hot
turn around and say I was wrong I
shouldn't have I shouldn't have done
that I didn't I didn't mean to I was
acting out I knew it wasn't right at
night me and all the other dancers would
just stuff our faces with food
our joints were are were weary we were
icing all of our joints after the dance
you know we were just bloated at high
altitude in Denver trying to do a show
at the Colorado Springs Air Force
Academy
farting and [__] all over the place
it was wrong and I'm sorry but now I'm
hot
and I disowned the fat people they are I
am no longer the queen of fat people
lizzo look at me and watch me don't make
the mistake
don't get fatter God forbid
get thinner now
hot lizzo
salad lizzo
lizzo comes out with keto salad dressing
yes or yes
there are so many economic opportunities
I should charge for this advice there
are so many economic opportunities right
now you've milked them enough the fats
you've squeezed on the Rudders
you've milked them enough it's time to
get the healthy P the rogany crowd the
the wellness people the people that do
yoga that you know are reading about
water filtration systems the people that
are what non-GMO like lizzo and you
could like her song as good as hell like
imagine a lizzo song from a thin lizard
where she's like I used to be a pig
I was a big fat pig
but then I realized I was gross I was
disgusting
but now I'm hot and hardness is real and
it would be huge it would be huge my
legs used to chafe
rashes on my back and onto my titties
cause of the Sun but now I'm thin my
vagina smells much better now
I'm hot lizzo is hard and I'm gonna go
to heaven oh I'm gonna go to heaven with
my new thin [__] girls if you got a
thin [__] put your hands in the air
I I mean
that was freestyling freeballing it but
maybe that is good but that is the
advice for her you cannot double down
you can no longer be the queen of uh the
Hogs and the heifers it is time to move
on that is your free advice
heat it
or perish